church is being attacked and burned
unfortunately the tragic part of America
injury I do the racism and the legacy
from slavery I really feel is sustained
on a human character when houses of
worship or attack wherever it is
a number of my members are people who
lived through the civil rights struggles
churches were the places where people
were organizing to march into fight
non-violently
church is historically to
african-americans were the only place of
refuge during slaving years after so it
is a long rich heritage
so for someone to target a church it's
sending a message
st. Louis especially has always had a
very long history of division due to
racism we had a Jewish congregation come
and worship with us on Sunday we're very
thankful
if it was a synagogue if it was a
monster it was Hindu temple I would be
standing up saying as an American this
is outrageous and you know I was staying
in solidarity